i looked at it as i have an atm between
my legs and i just i'm just using it all
i got to do is put my card in and that's
it and put the pin number and boom money
just comes right out
it was like
[ __ ] is just
this treasure that women are born with
and i knew how to use it
all right
where are you from originally where'd
you grow up i grew up in durham north
carolina
up until i was 12
and then i moved to washington state
with my dad
until i was 16. and how was your
childhood my childhood was
very dysfunctional it was very
dysfunctional
i remember from a very early age i
probably say three or four years old my
dad
would take me with him to go
and cheat on my mom and i remember you
for and he used to do this for
for me it felt like a long time because
i remember going to school and my dad i
mean
i remember going to school and
going to my teachers and telling them oh
i have 18 brothers and sisters
and
they're like they thought that was wild
you know and like somehow my pain i
don't know how my parents found out but
somehow they found out
and um i remember my mom just like just
being like why are you lying to them you
don't have 18 brothers and sisters and
she just kind of left it alone you know
like my family thought it was funny but
really they didn't know that it was
because my dad was taking me to go see
all these women and i would just sleep
in the living room while he would just
go and have an affair and
seeing that
was wild
it was
and my dad did it so much that in
kindergarten
i remember seeing the guy that had a
crush on me and now somehow i'm at his
house
and
my dad is hanging out with his mom
and it was just weird it was just like
wow like i'm really seeing all these
women and like they all had kids and
like
but the dad was never around it was
it was different and then
on top of that my dad was very abusive
he was very mind [ __ ] i remember
seeing him drag my mother with my baby
sister in her hands
and he dragged her from the steps
outside and just dragged her outside
and was beating on her and she was just
crying and i just couldn't remember why
i didn't know i didn't understand why he
did what he did you know and not
understanding why my dad had so much
anger
and like my dad would just
beat us for
for no reason
it was it was dramatic my dad just had
really bad
really bad anger issues
and i just remember wanting to
get away from him so bad
and i couldn't you know even though he
would always threaten it he was like do
you want me to sing back to north
carolina and go live with your mom and
i'm like no
because like
what am i going to do there you know but
and then i don't know it was just weird
he was just he is so controlling and so
mind [ __ ] to the point where like
even when we moved to washington state i
didn't even have a choice like he asked
me i remember it was on a wednesday
right and he asked me he was like
so you know you know me and your mom are
getting a divorce and uh do you do you
want to come move to washington state
with me i was like no i'm going to stay
here
and then he was like well
too bad we already bought the plane
ticket and i'm not about to wait case
money so we're gonna you're gonna move
to washington state i'm like okay
and then friday i was literally in a
whole new household i was in i was the
only black girl in my whole entire
[ __ ] school that was weird and then
and then like i'm moving in with these
with i wouldn't i don't want to call
them these but moving in with my
step-sisters
and
everything was just different then to
get off the plane and see my dad kiss
another woman
it was just so everything was so
different everything was just like this
big like culture shock for no [ __ ]
reason like it was just
it was too much and
having to play family and she didn't
even like us she didn't want us to be
there she only kept us there because my
dad wanted us there and it's like i want
my mom and i couldn't have my mom and i
just i remember i wanted so bad
no thank you thank you
i just remember that i wanted my mom so
bad
i just wanted her so bad
and i couldn't have her
she was so far i come all the way
watched to stay and she's all the way to
north carolina and i couldn't do
anything about that
but
we had to stay and um
and that had to do with what we had to
deal with and it felt like it was like a
cinderella story
you know where you have like your they
weren't evil they didn't know any better
you know i don't blame them they didn't
know any better but they always got the
better end of the stick
than all of us so it was just it was
just weird like watching my dad like
cater to someone else's kids and us you
know
and like he always treated them so nice
and would always just be like why can't
you be more like them and it's like
i'm your kid why can't you know like why
can't you just love me for who i am you
know
it was just it was tough it was tough
i'm in an abusive relationship and i'm
16 years old in an abusive relationship
and he's super abusive and then i'm
i am four years down the line we're
still together and we have a kid
together our last year i decided i'm
like i don't want to be in this
relationship anymore like he gives me an
std and i gotta i'm like i gotta go you
know he's sexually abusive mentally
abusive emotional abuse
anything you can think of that's abusive
that [ __ ] was it he was abusive
and so i was like i gotta go i gotta get
out of here so then i get out of there
but
like
like two months down the line i lose my
job
so um i'm jobless and i
do not have a place to call my own and
so i'm like sleeping on a couch at my
friend's grandma well not a couch
there's bed but
i'm sleeping in her home
and
i need some cash my car broke down and
um
like i need money to fix it so then i go
and i meet with ronnie right and
found him on back page never heard a
back page before
my best friend showed me that
so i meet up with ronnie and he has
all these liquor bottles in his uh
cabinet because this is he does the
this he says that i was supposed to do
like a massage or whatever
and i was like cool like he's like yeah
they're like these older men they love
it when young women come and they give
them a massage and i was like awesome
like this is cool i'm like that's all i
gotta do is a massage i was like great
you know and he was like i'll make all
this money but he has this lit all these
liquor in his um
and his cabinet and he's just like
you know i have if you can have as many
drinks as you want i'll make as many
drinks as you want i have feminine
products if you need them if you need a
douche if you need panty liners we need
condoms or anything like condoms
and then he's like yeah i don't know
like you know like for yourself i'm like
oh okay
and then um
i go and uh i have him make me a drink
and he's like yeah this is gonna really
keep you calm it's gonna keep you calm
this is all within the first day of
meeting him and then he's like but i
also have xanax
and mind you this guy is a counselor
he works for he works with mental health
patients he's a [ __ ] counselor
he's sick but he has xanax and he's like
um
do you want some i was like i've never
had xanax before what is that he's like
oh it'll just keep you calm
he's like you'll just feel super relaxed
i was like
okay
so he's like usually people football it
that's like retake the whole thing but
i'm like he's like but since you know
you know just take a third of it i'm
like all right so then i take a third of
it and i'm drinking and i still don't
feel it so i take another part of the
third
well the the second part of it because
it's cut up into three
and so i take the second part and then
like i'm really feeling feeling really
groovy and then the first client comes
over and
um i do my thing and at this point
that's when like
ronnie's like telling me like you know
you you gotta like
provide sexual services and he tells me
this while i'm high so like i don't give
a [ __ ]
and then um i'm like oh [ __ ] it whatever
you know and then uh then he's telling
me all the prices and the upgrades and
the client comes over and i do my thing
or whatever and then the second guy
comes and uh
ronnie can see it because he has his
xbox camera on and he's connected to his
tv in his room and the guy and i'm
laying down and
the guy's like i want to give you a
massage so he gives me a massage and i'm
blacked out at this point now i'm gone i
remember anything that happens comes to
find out
ronnie like wakes me up and i just see
him running out of his room with a gun
and then i guess apparently the guy was
trying to rape me and take advantage of
me and i'm like pass the [ __ ] out
and then ronnie scares them off and then
that [ __ ] scares me the [ __ ] off and i'm
like i don't want to do this like this
is not me i'm like no no no but he was
still my [ __ ] he would tell me like
come on make some money and i and i went
back a couple times and
but then like there was one time where
like um my ph balance you know like
yeast infection came around and that's
when i was like
i was like i can't work today and then
he was so pissed he was just like nah
don't worry about it then don't [ __ ]
come back and i was like what he was
like yeah no you're done i'm done with
you i'm like what i'm like i need the
money you know
so then i was like ah whatever that's
not gonna work out so then my friend
went back on back page and then she
found the spa
and that's when everything changed and
then
um
i
met up with uh maddie and victoria they
were the first spa owners i ever met
and they were so so sweet they were so
so nice and i told them i was like look
i don't want to have sex
with any men i was like if i have to do
that then i i'm out i don't want to do
this and then she's like if i find out
you're having sex at my spa i will fire
you i was like cool so here i am i'm
working at a jack shack right
and um
i'm working at a jack shack and
it's weird it is weird like the pricing
and everything is weird so like they
charge 60 dollars for 30 minutes that's
just to get in and it's an it's 80 for
an hour and then then that's that money
doesn't go to me that goes to the owners
and then they tip you on top of that
and um
and then
you know they tip you however much you
want you know but but the spa i worked
at or they were like weirdos they were
like weirdo weirdos like
there was this guy i think his name was
something like that but he liked to
pluck my hair
and floss his teeth with it
and then yeah a
weird and then he had a foot fetish so i
would sit up on the bed
like oh sorry
i would sit up on the bed like this and
then have my foot out
and he would drink water off of it and
he would like praise my foot like he
loved it and then like i would um
i would like choke him with my foot like
in his mouth just like in there just ugh
and he loved it and he and he just and
he
he was so happy and then this one guy
came in one time before and um
but my best friend saw him and he would
shut the whole place down he dropped
fifteen hundred dollars
right and he wanted you to [ __ ] him in
the ass and he wanted you to pee in his
mouth and i think he wanted you to take
a [ __ ] on him
but i do know he wanted you to [ __ ] him
in the ass and pee in his mouth
yeah and they pay you for that it's so
weird men are so [ __ ] weird but i
didn't last that long at that spa
um
it was the eos yeah eo spa in charlotte
um
it didn't last very long they got shut
down and then i was like well i gotta
find somewhere else i was literally on
my way to work that day
and when i got a call i was about to
like i was like a couple blocks down and
i got a call they're like don't come in
don't come in the feds are here the feds
are here i was like okay fine all right
i won't go so then i'm like what the
[ __ ] i'm gonna do for work so then i go
back on my good old back page again and
i find um
a place called
and that one's also run by a female as
well and but she's very good at what she
does she's very mind controlling and
very mind [ __ ]
she's she's mean she's very very mean
she used to make us wear heels
14 hours a day
mind you we only worked like three four
times out of the week
but
we were forced to wear those heels 14
hours out of the day and she told us you
will get naked for 80 dollars it's just
yeah i guess i had a woman pimp
yeah i had a woman pimp yeah she was
like you will get naked for 80
you will
let them touch you for 100 and you will
uh and it all comes with a hand job it
doesn't matter like even if they tipped
you 60 and it was topless then you still
have to give them a hand job
i was just like this but mind you i come
from abusive father i come from an
abusive
um
ex boyfriend
i'm used to this [ __ ] i'm used to just
turning off the switch and just doing
what people tell me to do
so i do it and then um
then i uh
stay with her for a while but then she
just gets really mind [ __ ] i can't do
it she was she was too much but i did
make really good money from it though
but um
but she also had weird clients too i
had a guy my last client there
he um
he paid me a hundred and forty dollars
just to piss in his mouth not to touch
his dick just to pee in his mouth
just the penis mouth yeah just the penis
mouth
yeah weirdo and um
uh
oh yeah and spit in his face and yeah in
the spit in his face but to like look at
him like a like spit in his face and
call him like
names but like looking at the floor it
was so weird it was so complicated but
i'm so glad that i got 140 just for
doing that
um
but yeah but then i left her
and then um
i
also met had met sugar daddies there as
well so i used to be like what you call
like a professional sugar baby and then
i went to
various different other spas that didn't
really
they weren't really my thing but then my
best one i went to was
that one i started doing full service
that one got
crazy they i mean
you could charge from anywhere from 800
to 900 to
600 300 for just been just [ __ ] you
just repo this for some [ __ ] this was a
[ __ ] that's not even talking about like
a head like just for [ __ ] and then men
don't i mean from my experience they
don't last that long they last like what
five ten minutes
not even like and that's like
i made half of somebody's check that
they would that they would get in two
weeks in 30 minutes and i didn't even
have to pop it for that long
you know and
but then you also have more weirdos
there
and
they
had one guy pay me 300 just to fart in
his mouth
just to fart in his mouth and then um
there was one guy
while he's [ __ ] you
he wants you to sound like a pig he
wants you to go
[Laughter]
that was so funny
and then um then there's an obviously
you got your peers i want you to pee on
them that
that never changes you still pee on them
they want you to pee on them which was
funny and then um
and then you had some that wanted you to
uh
to finger them in their ass you
obviously wear gloves for that i'm not
no
and then you had some that um
my favorite was john he paid money for
nothing he didn't want you to touch his
dick
he didn't want to do nothing but just
spank him and he would give you 900
just right there just right there and he
was a regular and he would and he loved
it and he'd come in like all dressed up
and
and he was just and he would just
speak so nice and so soft and he would
just
he was just like yeah
yeah i'm having such a great day yeah
and then he'd get in the room and then
he puts his he wants you to have his
panties laid out and his bra and his
little stockings that come up here that
have the little ruffles on them and then
he wants you to have his paddle out in
his little bunny butt plug and then
sometimes he'll have his um his dick
chamber that you have to put a lock on
he wants that there too
sometimes it just depends on what he's
into yeah that day
and um then you spank him for about 30
minutes and sometimes he'll want two
girls and then he'll have two girls come
in and then sometimes three and then the
next thing you know you got the whole
spa on there and then uh yeah it was
he was amazing i loved him sometimes he
would come in and only pay 300. but most
times he paid a lot of money he paid
really really good money
but
to shed some light on it a lot of the
girls in there
are not
forced to be there we are there because
we want it to be there or we want to be
there for my friends that are still
there they want to be there they're not
sex trafficked they're not forced to be
there they
that's their craft that's what they want
to do but most girls that are in there
they don't realize that they have a lot
of trauma
and they realize that they
um
that they're hurting still you know like
me like when i was in it i didn't
realize that
i was so good at what i did
because i've been so sexually abused and
i had been so hurt
and raped so many times that i was able
to just click it off
and when i went to work i was michelle
when i went to work i was naomi when i
went to work i was um
haley when i went to work you know
oh my god some kendall
gigi so many different i was somebody
else i was when i went there i was no
longer what people knew me as nicole i
wasn't that
you know i wasn't taiyee as my family
knows me i wasn't that i was
all of the above i was somebody else you
know and that's why it made it easy for
me to do it but
eventually it gets old eventually you
have to get out of that but it is
it was one hell of a
one hell of a time did you save money
did i save money yes i did that's how i
got here
because i see so that was that was
charlotte north that was charlotte north
carolina charlotte is a big hub
for um
for sex trafficking and
for um like sex jobs and stuff so and
did doing this for how many years two
years yeah two three years yeah did it
change the way you see men yeah a lot it
changed the way i see married men
because 99 of the men that came in were
married
and
i apologize if i messed up any marriages
um
but i never looked at it that way i
looked at it as you put 300
you put 400 whatever you put money on
that table and my [ __ ] was okay with it
it was over
i looked at it as i have an atm between
my legs and i just i'm just using it all
i got to do is put my card in and that's
it and put the pin number and boom money
just comes right out
it was like
[ __ ] is just
this treasure
that women are born with
and i knew how to use it
but
i only knew how to use it because that's
what they would take away from me that's
what men would do to me they would take
that it would take my dignity away from
me so
yeah
and you make a lot of money from it so
so the downside is it
kind of
undermines your
self-worth or your your happiness sort
of yeah and
and even like my boy my ex-boyfriend
when i moved to charlotte like i met him
through there and we dated for two years
and
it
[ __ ] me up hard
like trying to fall back in love again
it [ __ ] me up like because it was just
like he wasn't mind controlling he
wasn't my [ __ ] he was a good guy he
just loved prostitutes he just loved
like
not girls that would go into like the
spas whatever i i must have been
different
but
he i'd always catching he was always
talking to prostitutes like you always
like
call them and then like texting them and
i'm like dude like
knock knock you got a
escort right here
you know at home like wake up i guess i
guess i just wasn't enough for him i
guess i don't know but that
that [ __ ] me up you know like that i'm
messed up on you know but i did have a
good time
i did enjoy myself
i did um
i didn't let it hurt me i didn't let it
affect me
i did i have something to show for it
that's one thing i always wanted to make
sure that i had something to show for it
and i do i i traveled as much as i could
i
my daughter never had to worry about
anything she the way my daughter is
right now is because of how i of how
much i spoiled her the girl literally
thinks she's a princess and the only
thing she's missing is her [ __ ]
castle i swear
she's so
fortunate until this day she's still
fortunate because her mom set her up so
well so your life is good today my life
is so good today even though even though
like with the whole um
with the whole eviction moratorium
whatever
we're so good you know we're still
we're still living okay you know what
how are you supporting yourself now now
um well before golden cross shut down it
was golden corral but they just called
me back to go back to work so
that was such a weird transition so
where are you working oh golden crown
oh a restaurant yeah yeah the restaurant
yeah um as a waitress
um that was a weird transition to
trying to get away from that i i started
out as a supervisor at cvs
and then i got tired of that and then i
moved to
golden cross
and then that's what i do now yeah
walking away from sex work is it's so
hard because you make so much money like
i remember like my second day working
there i made 1600 in one day
in one day that is somebody's paycheck
that takes them like two weeks to get
and now at cvs or at your restaurant
you're making how much oh god uh barely
300 in the weekend right maybe that
that's back when before the pandemic you
know that's a hard adjustment it's a
hard adjustment yeah but i knew what i
was getting myself into you know i knew
it i knew what i was getting myself into
so i had to prepare myself for it
what i was doing was
for my desires it wasn't doing anything
for me spiritually
i was letting anybody just be inside of
me as long as they put the right amount
of money on that table
it's like i didn't give i didn't give a
[ __ ] you know but
because at the end of the day the most
the less
the last i ever walked out with at a
nice spa
i mean like on a slow day i'd make like
600
and that's probably from seeing like two
people
and
not even having to have sex still
and the most like on a regular basis on
at most
1200 900
you know a day i'm set
i'm set i can travel do whatever the
[ __ ] i want to do you know
but it's like you gotta train your mind
to get out of a situation like that you
know you gotta train your mind to think
like i don't need these things these
things aren't important and that was
hard
because going from oh i can just
i don't i can just buy that you know
even like switching from like i can't
just go on amazon anymore and just like
go on a shopping spree like that like i
gotta
really just be like oh i guess i'll save
it for later type [ __ ] you know
like it's it's terrible it's a terrible
mindset
like
i'm young i'm 20 years old making
a [ __ ] ton of money before i'm 21
and then i'm 23 i already own two cars
like that are paid off they're not i'm
not leasing them i'm not i don't owe
money on them no they are completely
paid off in my name what 23 year old has
that kind of [ __ ] except you know what
what would you say to a young you're 24
now i'm 24 now so what would you say to
a young girl who's considering doing
something like this because times are
tough right now money is don't do it
don't do it unless unless you have
sexual trauma
unless you have sexual trauma that is
the only way that it will allow you to
get through this because men
men treat you like you are like they
just went through a fast food
um
drive-through and they're literally
looking at you like you're on the menu
at mcdonald's literally like a lot of
times i had to tell those men i'm just
like
they're like oh well can you do it for
this much i'm like no like you can't
even go to mcdonald's and ask them oh
can i have a big mac for one dollar no
if the price is what the price is
okay you can't just like you can't just
try to talk an employee out of giving
you a damn big mac for like for two
dollars you can't that's impossible you
know and so it's like you got to know
how to be strong and to put your foot
down now i do know while working there
it helped me be a strong woman a lot of
people
you know and even my boyfriend today
he still tries to say it like you know
you working there
made you less of a woman no it didn't it
may have made me less of a woman because
of what i did
but even then it taught me something
that my [ __ ] father didn't teach me
nor my nor my poor mother you know
they didn't teach me how to have a voice
and now i have a voice i stick up for
myself i don't let anybody talk down to
me i won't i won't allow it and because
i worked there i
learned to stick up for myself i learned
to speak up and i learned to not let
anybody talk down to me
tom
thank you so much for telling your
fascinating story
thanks very interesting thanks for
having me
you